good morning Hank it's Tuesday so
worldwide more than six million children
died in 2013 which is horrible and
unjust and unacceptable but it's also
the lowest that number has been in quite
a while even though the world population
is like steadily increased I think what
do you think the last time was that the
world saw fewer than 6.3 million
children die in a year 1975 when the
population of the world was 4 billion in
1900 when it was 1.6 billion no in 1900
probably more than 8 million children
died earth has not seen a year with so
few child deaths in hundreds of years
maybe a thousand years so Hank I'm a big
fan at the Gates Foundation the
organization set up by Bill and Melinda
Gates that his favorite mission
statement ever devoted to the idea that
all people deserve the chance to live a
healthy and productive life and build
another to just released this
fascinating letter highlighting three
myths about development and yes I can
call them Bill and Melinda perhaps
you're not familiar with the rule of
Twitter following which I just made up
whereby you can call anyone you follow
on Twitter by their first name see also
my acquaintances Barack Beyonce and
Ellen
reiben anyway Billy Melinda's three
myths first it is not true that poor
countries will forever be poor and I get
this all the time especially about
Africa that despite their rich natural
resources those countries are just
doomed to stay poor or yeah no I mean
for one thing seven of the ten
fastest-growing economies of the last
five years are in Africa to quote bill
you should look skeptically at anyone
who treats an entire continent as an
undifferentiated mass of poverty and
disease it is not fair that Bill Gates
gets to be both a billionaire and a good
writer okay it's time to put aside
personal jealousy and return to
statistics adjusted for inflation
Botswana's income per person in 1960 was
$383 it's now $12,000 $48,000 for a
family of four now that's an extreme
example but this is happening around the
world in the last 50 years income per
person in India has quadrupled in Brazil
it is nearly quintupled the second myth
is that foreign aid is a waste okay
quick quiz guess what percentage of your
country's budget is spent on foreign aid
the answer is 3 percent if you're
Norwegian in the United States it's less
than 1 percent and even with that small
investment we've seen tremendous results
25 years ago there were 350,000 new
cases of polio a year today thanks to
the aid funded Polio Eradication
Initiative there are fewer than 400
malaria and measles and TB have all
declined dramatic
me and healthier kids go to school more
and then they work more when they grow
up than they would if they were
chronically ill or disabled and the last
myth is that saving lives leads to
overpopulation I hear this all the time
and it's just not true population growth
declines as infant mortality declines
all over the world it is that simple
to quote Melinda we make the future
sustainable when we invest in the poor
not when we insist upon their suffering
boom the boom is in part of the court as
does my addition ensuring these
investments are showing phenomenal
returns and the greatest risk we face is
abandoning our success because we
wrongly think of it as failure I'm gonna
say it again
fewer children died in 2013 than in any
year on record and all this means just
to be clear a better world not only for
those living in poverty but also for the
rest of us I know this is counter to a
lot of what you hear on the news but
wealthier countries benefit when poor
countries become less poor for one thing
there are more people on the earth with
the education and well-being to make
wonderful things from paintings to
smartphone apps but there are also more
people to buy the stuff that we make
whether that's artificial lips or for
example my novel The Fault in Our Stars
Hey the Brazilian edition of tokyo's is
called a Copa aid us estrellas
he said butchering the Portuguese you
know I can't say the title the book it's
sold hundreds of thousands of copies in
Brazil it's more popular there than in
Germany or the UK a country once deemed
incurably poor now has by some measures
a healthier book publishing landscape
than many countries in Europe and it's
not just Brazilians who benefit from
Brazil's phenomenal growth it's also
young adult novelists in Indianapolis so
thanks to everyone in Brazil who's
bought my book and thanks to the Gates
Foundation for decreasing world suck and
busting those myths there's a link to
Bill & Melinda letter in the doobly-doo
it really is worth reading Hank I will
see you on Friday